foreign
hello this penis party's got to go
uh we're waiting on a guest
ladies always always running on ladies
got to put their makeup on the good face
on yeah yeah the tampons the maxi pads
you name it
nah I'm joking oh let's open with a
peeve okay this is one of my best
friends Rachel Feinstein who's on the
episode today and she this is her excuse
why she's running late she called me and
she goes uh oh thank you very much this
is a Campari soda
oh that looks nice
she wanted a vodka soda thank you
Danielle I'll tell you something
when it's hot out like this and the
city's getting warm again I crave a
Campari soda there's something old man
Italian about it I kind of like it it's
a summer drink it's refreshing it's a
good cocktail oh yeah all right what do
I got here gin and tan
pocket avocaton
Rodger soda nothing wrong with that so
um this is the peeve that's that's good
she goes I put in the old Studio address
yeah and then she tells me she's on 44th
street I was like well that has nothing
oh with the old Studio you caught her on
that one she's full of shaded I let her
have it well we're gonna let her have it
when she comes in here yeah the moon
Alice
yeah one time a guy got me he goes uh
why didn't he answer my calls he called
me and I didn't answer and I texted him
and he goes why didn't you answer I go
I'm driving and he's like so you don't
answer the phone when you're driving you
text and I was like damn it he got me I
actually had a friend who was so dumb he
would do that what he would I would call
him and he would text back driving right
now and I was like yeah he's dumb enough
to do this ah yeah wasn't you he's a guy
who's actually dumb enough to text and
drive but I shouldn't talk on the phone
but I'll text right I think it's illegal
to talk on the phone while driving is it
is that illegal maybe not with the car
play because you can just go hey how are
you but the texting is definitely
illegal they're getting a little carried
away on the on the iPhone with the uh
the driving thing I was walking the
other day and I said are you driving I
was like I'm walking slowly oh yeah what
are we doing here I know what did I ever
tell you this I was driving L.A and I
was texting and I look over and a guy's
in a car next to me goes
and I was like oh [__] it felt like a
dad I wanted to blow him
I was like turned on like this guy I was
like you're right you got it you did got
me dead the right you could spanking
after that yeah bend me over take it
Daddy I uh I did that once I walked into
some we were both on our phones and we
walked into each other ah and we were
both mad at the other person like my
phone thing was more important than your
phone right yeah I've seen a guy walk
into a pole before while texting and
that's very satisfying the stripper yeah
it's not even paying attention while
they're dancing anymore I tell you yeah
strippers no respect
strippers are taking venmo now are they
really yeah they get a little barcode
temporary tattoo with a little uh QR the
homeless have got a figure of venmo out
oh no they're getting crushed killed out
there no one's known as cash no cash I
know I love cash I'm all cash yeah well
we still get paid in cat it's nice
having cash on it I love having cash
yeah and it's easier for tipping you
throw one in the uh the bucket you know
yeah which bucket the what the bathroom
attendant or something well like at the
pizza place you pop a one in the jar or
the coffee shop you pay I never pay by
cash though I mean yeah it's fun to like
throw in like a whatever a tip but I'm
okay I hate the the [__] screen
turning around and you go uh I give you
the 20 and you have to sign I hate that
that thing here's here's a one here's a
two yeah I'm not signing [__] why do you
hate it I just don't like them looking
at me typical so they know yes it's too
intrusive because this way it's more
like it's unexpected like the expected
tip isn't exciting they're like yeah you
know you should give this but when it's
you're like oh no and here's something
exactly it should be on my my own
volition that makes sense yeah I don't
want you gonna ask me to tip now I have
to tip the Tipping of the whole point of
it is here you go it's a gift yeah now
it's an obligation look at this in our
Bodega Cat shirts oh yeah it's looking
kind of cool rapping baby look at that
this is a little small on me this is a
type but that's all they had yeah yeah
I'll wear it you'll wear it all right
now you don't want to see my hairy
physique yeah but at a future time you
don't want to see this Holocaust body oh
yeah kidding me it looks like a garlic
knot that fell on the floor of a
barbershop
where do you stand on garlic knots I
think it's overrated it's all just bread
it's here's they can be done really well
a garlic or not but yeah it's like I'm
at the pizza place why am I gonna get
exactly here we go
[Music]
there's like a Kramer entrance
how are you there hey rage like Mary
Poppins you whis in here well you need a
microphone here hi this is Danielle I'm
Danielle nice to meet you hi
[Music]
all right
Okay so
so
I did I accidentally went to I put in
the Uber okay first of all you guys
moved addresses that's true that's true
a year and a half ago so um a year and a
half ago so I haven't been here since
then so then um I was like oh the old
one was right by Caroline's so I put
Caroline's in there but I put Caroline's
school or something like it requires
comedy club which is also no longer here
which is also no longer here yeah and
then I was just like on the phone and
Austin I realized I was like oh wait not
only are we not there but we're like at
Caroline's school like not even there's
Comedy Club but like their school and I
was like [__] and I was so proud of
myself too it was gonna be a few minutes
early like I have my [__] together this
is a new [__] rage and I was like I'm
gonna get a slice on the way in all of a
sudden I was like oh yeah
uh yeah and then Sam called me and I was
like really hoping that you guys didn't
run a tight ship but weirdly enough for
being like such a mess you run a tight
[__] [__] we gotta hit we gotta have
a regimented schedule yeah usually but I
will say that I'm usually on time and I
was on time no no not for social
engagements before it works
which one is this yeah is it social work
this is both you are one of the friends
where I'm like I'm gonna show up 15
minutes late and then I'm still 15
minutes early
definitely no socially I'm pretty
worthless you do have a kid though at
least you have that excuse having a kid
gives you you know that's an excuse
that's gonna be what my book is it's
gonna be like as a mom juggling at all
something something Jaeger
I saw a clip with Chris D and he's like
anyone who doesn't have kids who
complains is a [__] [__] you gotta
go get your [__] done you don't have
kids I have kids it's so hard you can't
find a relationship [__] you I have kids
it is funny like the things that your
friends without kids like will complain
about you know like like they'll be like
oh yeah like this girl wouldn't leave
after I [__] her and I'm like you know
what dude you know I told you that in
confidence all right I wasn't gonna say
your name by the way I literally stopped
myself that was pretty rude but also
kids never leave good luck trying to get
rid of one of them they're always there
it's my pedophile should know okay
yeah but my like um uh I I don't know if
I'm allowed to say this in the podcast
okay but like James like he was supposed
to shoot something with me and my
husband on Sunday and he's like
um like a mom excuse would be like oh my
friend you know my daughter has a fever
or whatever or something
you know anything like that um James
Webb the director James I love James
is like I was like so we're gonna
definitely shoot Sunday he's like I'm
thinking about tripping
just doing drugs might do shrooms is the
best excuse and the most honest excuse
I've ever heard that's the moment where
you're like just make up something yeah
I might decide to trip but I haven't
decided yet is the worst question damn
he's honest I respect that it's fun
because he shot my special and I got all
these big wig agents there and he
wouldn't give them a time of day and you
could tell it really [__] with them
they're like who's this guy a jacked
muscly dude walking around a tank top
yes and all these suits are trying to
talk to him and he's just like walking
around looking like a Blade Runner extra
yeah he's got the gear on the big uh
steady Cam Body he was like live with me
for a while and it was really hilarious
yeah well he was going to come to New
York the father yes he's the dad of my
child yeah James banged me for a while
I got stuffed up by James no actually
not only does James like not even file
me in the category of a woman but I was
telling him something was about like you
know when you're like does this person
even know I'm a woman like I'm like I
don't think he even realizes it I was
actually like telling a story about
somebody that that was clearly hitting
on me and on Instagram and James was
like nah I don't see yeah come on
there's no way even Sam was like no I
think he's he has had a pretty direct DM
hitting and he's like nah couldn't be
possible he's like no way are you
reading into this every story where I
even like forward like a light
compliment James is like come on I
crunched the numbers on that possible
you're dreaming yeah he just doesn't
even see me as a female which is fine
that's fine some people file you under
females some people do you ever feel
like that like where some women register
you as a man and other ones you're like
of course yeah yeah yeah I'm a twink or
uh you know I'm just a blah I'm an
asexual I'm neutral you know it's a bad
feeling a woman calls you like buddy or
Pal like that [__] I don't care for
that even even if I know they're married
I'm like you better I want them sexual
tension in the mix still yes yeah of
course although women are trickier
whether they're attracted to you and
I've said this to you before Sam because
sometimes like you'll think somebody is
not into and I'm like no that's just her
playing it highly manipulative subtle
game and I've done that too so she might
be buddying you because she wants you to
sure but then you have the guy who uses
that like oh she Oh that girl hates you
no no that's how she flirts and you're
like no no she hates it
how does that side of it too she gave
you the finger across the street she
wants yeah it is a convenient place to
file anybody that's mean to you or
rejecting you my brother said that to me
once just probably because he felt sorry
for me I was like this guy is really
mean to me he's like he's probably
attracted to you and I'm like that's
such a healthy thing to tell you right
right whenever somebody's just not
interested in hanging out with you or
doesn't care for your comedy too
probably really aroused by me yeah I
mean you see guys do all the time like
oh they're just jealous like oh they
[__] on you my ACT yeah but they're just
jealous I'm like I wish I had that I'm
like yeah my ACT does suck I go I agree
with him I have a friend who's so
confident with women and he's like I
remember he went to a girl drunk and a
boy once he goes let's be honest you
came here to get [__] and she was like
no idea
[Music]
would you believe it didn't work
that was actually my great aunt Edith
Schneider's pickup line he also used to
say that yeah that would work well for a
woman she would often walk into the deli
that would see a guy you know and be
like hey Seymour you came here to get
[__] come on
you want one thing and that's this sweet
[__]
let's be honest you came here to get
[__] as one of the funniest you got a
good pickup line nah not I mean I I I
have a few things that are fun you know
what would you go to my go-to is a man
if I wasn't gay and then they go oh too
bad I go I'm not
you see me do that Rachel see me do one
of them which is the one I'll be the
boss yeah well I'll go up to a group of
bar and I'll pretend to be on the phone
and I'll be I'll be like 20 million for
the Children's Hospital that's not
enough money we have to make more and
then I'm sorry I have to take this call
it's very important that's good that
usually works that's good usually at
least a smile I've never seen it not
work back in the day when we used to
actually go out together and like try to
Wing each other Sam would pull that one
and it would be it would be which is a
way better look for men being with a
woman because you're like he's not a
murderer he's with a woman but yeah any
favors to be with me
this guy's drunk right right now people
were just like highly suspicious of me
and Sam like you know it worked first
example I'm like oh you can trust him
I'm like an appendage to trusting
exactly yeah but yeah when he would like
hang around near me and I would talk to
a guy they'd just be like what are you
guys trying to do are you trying to rob
me or like or co-rape me like what's
happening is that it's not good luck Sam
would be like hey the next something and
the guy was just like I'd be like look
at her see her not gonna kill you come
here I use will for that I have will
standing there I'm like ah black joke
black joke
[Laughter]
[Music]
everybody
well the thing is you can get away with
with will next to you on stage when
you're yabba-dabba Doo Oh my God forget
about it the worst is when you're
riffing with Will and the audience
groans and you're like I went too far
with will yeah that's a bad sign true
because he You Really Gonna Get at he
gets to get a jail free card with the
juice stuff with me though yeah oh my
god oh good point
um this is like such a twatty way to
start a sentence and I realize I come
off as an absolute [__] but my
housekeeper
my hard life no okay she comes every
couple weeks she doesn't live with me
but anyway so we've had a pretty close
relationship for you know for like she
comes everyone a couple weeks to like
clean
um over shared with her to a great
degree that's what probably like webs
had been held by her mom it's not good
anyway but I thought we were like super
close and I swear to God she was like in
the middle of cleaning and she stopped
and she goes uh she goes my friend
Mariana she works for a Jewish people
and she's like a bad people no
oh she didn't know and she said it's no
she knows oh that's even weird and I
would check out the story that's why she
was asking me she's like it's bad people
no like and then I was like are they
like sitting I got I slowly gathered
that they were like considered shoes you
know and she's like they like they did
not nice to her they make her watch the
walls they make her eat outside and
separate the food so I tried to explain
like being kosher to her you know oh and
I was like I was really proud of my like
speech I was like well with with any
extreme religion I was like you're gonna
get a lot of repression a lot of these
guys go to prostitutes you know and
things any extreme religion sure go in a
hooker and all kinds of weird stuff's
happening for any like fundamentalist
religion I'm like really thinking I'm
like wow what a marvelous monologue
You're weaving to teach or not to hate
Jews and then she goes but she was just
a bad right
and then I tried to explain the
Holocaust and I was like some of the
reasons why she goes they have 10 kids
it's gross right not necessary I have
some kids I was like I mean I don't
disagree with no that is weird it's a
weird yeah but you know it's kind of
lost when you have to explain the
Holocaust I know it might be over when
you throw your light in let me explain
the 1940s here like no it's too late
once you're like searching up the jury's
in your phone it's not a good one but
Jewish is tough because you can't always
tell it's not like a black guy or an
Asian guy so you must hear some juice
stuff some Jew hate and people go oh I
didn't know that was you because you
know you might not know you're Jewish
out of the gate I've got I've gotten
that before people think Italian
sometimes yeah yeah oh yeah
after I heard you speak I'd be like
definitely a Jew really the prettiest
girls are always friendships
she doesn't register as a woman
there's an entity yeah wait what do you
mean what'd you say how do you know she
was Jewish but she's speaking nasally I
don't know really easily no not nasally
but it's a Jewish voice it's a Jewish
voice yeah all right I'm learning people
like under all my videos just talk about
my voice so apparently I have like a
very annoying very like nasal
problematic yeah you just like looked at
me like you were trying not to agree so
quickly like I'm gonna give it a second
just staring off
no no it's a fine voice I mean look
who's talking I sound like a [__]
robot I'm inviting the comments to just
explode oh bring it on we need the algo
we need the comments keep commenting
guys yeah fight in the comments go nuts
yeah and I also when I showed her the
picture of the of the Holocaust like I
actually showed up a picture of like
some kids I was like see they killed all
these people and here they are like
shaking a fence and I was like oh my
Lord I was like so that's the reason why
they want to have so many kids by the
way please feel free to fact check me
because I have no information I think
you're right that's true that's why Jews
want to marry Jews too right and why
they because they don't know if the
Holocaust is ever going to happen again
so I explained it to her and I showed
her like some of the some like Jewish
kids holding a fence and she was like
she just kind of shrugged like she was
like yeah she'd never heard of this she
didn't know about the Holocaust I'm not
sure wow but it was one I thought I
thought we were doing pretty good PR
getting it out there yeah
my mom will do [__] like that when my
mom will call me and be like you know
there was a I had a taxi driver today
and he was just you know saying how Jews
are cheap and bad people so of course I
didn't leave him a tip and I'm like good
job Mom you showed him yeah way to break
the the stereotypes reminded me to tip
the Uber driver
well I'm glad I brought that up
I have my next Uber does anybody do that
like I don't remember to put it he just
looks up he goes Feinstein
[Music]
I don't put it in until I take the next
ride is anybody else I'm the same place
so I just kind of think that's an okay
time to do it no is that true or not
sure yeah as long as you tip them okay
okay yeah but what the tough thing about
the Uber is well what do you tip a cab
two bucks well I just tipped him 20
because I'm 20. I promised him twenty
percent cash if he would take me here
because I realized because I already
ended the ride
and then I realized I didn't give him
anything
oh that's hilarious I just but it was
only four blocks different okay yeah
yeah all right good you're a good person
good I am I'm just remind him of how it
cost you know I just took you didn't tip
well look at these children pull up a
photo look at that they're hugging a
fence it was such a dumb moment why did
he need to show her a picture of like
like cute pics you need to watch
Holocaust dogs as a Jew because yeah we
complained so much culturally that it
does for just this brief period put
things in perspective well I'm like this
[__] happened there's construction in
my building and then you watch it like
oh Otto Frank wasn't granted citizenship
and they died all right as a family yeah
all you have to do is look up typhus you
think I'm being a [__] in a store just
be like typhus kids Holocaust oh I don't
know typhus well they all just like died
of typists and all kinds of other
gangrenous diseases in the camps which
is why I can be like a [__] [__] in a
deli yeah sure
that makes sense no I think that I feel
like we we're pretty good we both tip
pretty well we also also but we just
over analyze everything and like that's
also like yeah I think a lot of people
were in our heads but uh I do think it's
like a very New York thing like so much
is coming at you all day that you'll be
on the subway like you know like oh my
God like this [__] this [__] this
[__] [__] here no respect no
decency and then you see someone come on
with no legs and you're like what am I
complaining about yeah then you get to
the next stop and another guy bumps you
and you're like this [__] [__]
right you know it reminds me of that
scene from sci-fi one of my favorite
scenes ever when like they're all at a
funeral and she's like and then like
everybody's just like wailing sobbing
and Elaine's like I feel like I wear the
same thing yeah and again and again yes
so true
everyone's got their own process yeah
yeah yeah a friend of mine she has like
like twins and she's like talking about
trying to get their house ready because
one of them can't walk and they need
like us they need to like you know
wheelchair proof the house and put these
like ramps up and then I'm just like I
feel like I should be playing larger
theaters
I always feel bad whenever I see a
wheelchair at an airport I sit in it
because I'm like ah seat and then
somebody will be like hey I'm using this
like yeah
I get it I'm like look at this I'm doing
wheelies you just find this out right
now this is amazing you guys know
no but I will use an occasional handicap
Stall oh no one's ever you never I could
literally never tell if Mark is joking
do you I do you I thought you were being
ironically no no that's crazy well if
you see that if you see the wheelchair
person come up you move I don't think
it's crazy person is incredible
the handy capable okay I was dating this
guy once and his mom was complaining and
complaining this Russian guy about how
um they were like they they had no
friends when they first moved to the
country and her example of how her kids
weren't popular she's like she was like
friends with the wheelchair
[Laughter]
There's Something Beautiful about people
that don't fully know the language
because they're they're blunt honestly
yes yes it's kind of beautiful but
that's still pretty shitty to say like
of course so much of a loser there
friends with the old uh [__] you know
yeah like my friend was once like I
dated another guy before that and his
mother
um not my friend my ex his mother also
uh I came in one day and she was weeping
in the kitchen
um does also people that don't know
they're racist but are like aggressively
racist hello sure we think in the
kitchen and I was like what is wrong
what's happened and she's like well I
tell you this nice girl family she's
dating person with like a darker skin
like that like lovely doctor that she's
hating and she's like he's like from
like a place like maybe even the
[Laughter]
yeah and I was like yeah you know she's
sounds like a really lovely and like
positive person why do you think the
color of his kid is like so upsetting to
you and she's like maybe I'm like this
thing like if you don't like these
different dresses or something I love
that she was like openly trying to
figure out I'm like yeah racist yeah
like yes yeah I like that you have to
cheer her up too like it'll be okay
right yeah she's like it plays like even
the boat won't go
that's like Poetic yeah it's nice when
somebody's that openly because at least
you know where you know where you stand
and the word choice is so nice too the
boat good to know beautiful boat right
beautiful that's like old-timey right
it's like a Hemingway yeah
I love Mark's joke about how racist
disease
Mark is a joke about how when someone's
being racist with you you almost
appreciate it because you're like wow
that was terrible but I didn't know we
were so close yeah you didn't trust him
it was hilarious yeah if they're racist
you're like Norman you're full of hate
but at least you connect with them
intimacy yes exactly no that is true
when everybody do another one of those
thank you Danielle oh yeah thank you
sexual stuff too it's always good when
someone opens up like I like this like
what's his face I'm not gonna say oh but
he loves getting pegged by the way
everyone knows who you're talking about
[Laughter]
this is like a headline for you yes you
just saw the headline you're like that's
good enough for me yeah no he uh he said
uh he liked a finger in the butt so he
tried Peg and Peg and yeah it turns out
a finger is the perfect size oh I missed
that part that's the joke but that's
funny but his mom saw the special so I'm
sure he'll have a joke about the mom
seeing the peg oh yeah that is so
respect for putting that in the special
rough yeah good for run on thank you
Daniel but yeah pegging I see him very
differently now yeah yeah I can't it
doesn't could you be with a guy you've
pegged like if you pegged a guy could
you keep dating him I have never done
anals since you asked Mom
you've never done it to you you've done
had it done okay I had a desire to do it
I don't like a lot of like foolishness
toys
it's a whole business I I went to a sex
store with a woman once she paid by the
way she put a card down before I even
get in it was over 400 worth of sex toys
whoa we didn't use one of them we tried
a person we're like this is this is
stupid oh my lady likes them really oh
she's got a drawer full of goodies
really oh yeah it's a toy chest it's
wild she knows how to use all of them oh
my God
because I don't read I can't read the
instructor I'm not gonna follow any
instructions well it's pretty
self-explaned they uh they vibrate they
penetrate they wiggle we've we've done
there's one we used but it was from a
preview she already had it and all the
stuff we bought I was like this is
excessive this is ridiculous yeah well
I'll finish to charge it all you feel
ridiculous you look at my nightstand we
had like four things charging at my
nightstand I know I look like a [__]
Predator what is this [__] I did I don't
remember what the podcast is but they
send you all these um sex toys oh yeah
so I got like 50 in the mail do you know
what I'm talking about I can't remember
I've gotten the flashlights and whatnot
so so the same housekeeper I just talked
about oh organize them like in on my top
shelf just like this bouquet of sex toys
so he just walked into my room and it's
just like I look like just a Godless
inexhaustible [__] yeah it's like on
the open shelving it's just like oh it's
like a teddy bear and Frankie on the end
and you got a surge protector there's no
way I can discuss it with her and be
like I don't use all of these because it
just sounds like all I do is just Jam
them right between my shoes at home she
comes home you come home she's dusting
them off the shelf they were organizing
these cute little things oh well they
are kind of cute they're little and pink
and blue you know one time I was like I
have to become more interesting in bed
because I'm like nobody's ever even
bothered to tell me I'm the best they've
ever had like no one would tell me that
lie no one's been able to look in my
eyes and be like it's never been better
yeah I gotta step it up and so I tried
to look up like some
and I Googled like like like naughty
games on Amazon I was like I really feel
like I'm 60 looking this up yeah and
then I got like a sex game I was like oh
maybe we'll play a game and the game is
just covered in Cox it's just like a
million drawn like [__] and veggies
like why would that be the artwork like
be discreet you know yeah it should be
like yeah this classy uh this board game
should have class and dignity that
you're trying to learn how to [__]
better my sexual board game is sorry
[Laughter]
well I finish in like two seconds a lot
so then I'll just go to town with the
problem over in our household oh really
uh yeah really so she's trying to so
she's trying to get I you know I feel
guilty so I want to get her off as well
so we'll pull out the old toy chest okay
and you're pretty good about it and
you're like yeah I want her to get off
and I'm get that little egg thing he
works there I love the egg yeah I love
the eggs I'll get two going at once two
eggs yeah oh yeah I'm overusing yeah I'm
scrambling
where did the eggs go
uh you know you put one up top one maybe
on the shoulder a little massage action
got a hard dick going on on her tries
remember when they used to advertise
that it'd be clearly like a magic wand
dildo and they're like oh it's good for
the neck like that was a commercial on
TV yeah I think I've never had like
weird sex dreams about somebody that
you're not even attracted to yes sure
highly sexual dreams yeah okay all right
dildo alarm
um yeah about same and they're hot I
want to stay in them I'm like whoa SD
all right how about this that was mine
it was somebody that I was like actually
I mean like I see is an attractive woman
I was like somebody that I'm not
attracted to at all so like okay it was
I was
um she's the book of the Conley Cellar
for people at home oh yeah we can
probably cut that out no keep it in it's
very important for our product that's
what she said keep it in
I had a dream that I like went down on
my why am I telling the seller the
housekeeper this is the problem with
drinking no on my like
12th grade I'm sorry senior year history
teacher who was like 85 like oh wow like
aggressively heinous she had like white
hair in her ear she's probably dead oh
it's a lady yes whoa and it was like and
I dreamed that I just like just went to
town how did her vagina look in the
dream was it was it better than you
expected I think it was no because I
think that the dream was that like first
of all I woke up like why the [__] would
I dream that I went down on Albert like
she was like this very serious militant
NFL government teacher like 85 years old
wow there's no way that I'm like
secretly attracted to her I think it was
like the fact that everybody at school
knew like not only did was she just like
spread eagle just which she should have
been teaching at cell government and I
was just deep in her snatch but
everybody in school knew that I'd gone
down or like they think they all walked
in and they're like oh we can't start
NSL government because racism
Wow have you ever been a lady no wow
that's fascinating I like I made out
with the girl once but you know that's
what everyone in the world sure yeah but
no I've never like
um but yeah I just I woke up just
rocking with shame and horror that
everybody at my high school would know
were they mocking you in the in the
class or no it was just like quietly
getting around it was worse than active
mockery it was like I was getting
strange looks odd interactions they're
like hmm were you just 69ing a city
teacher in the beginning of class and I
was like an impediment to them walking
in the class because I was just there
just really yeah fisting the history
teacher I've had a few dreams like that
where there's that soft knowledge around
that I [__] someone in a very
inappropriate place like on the floor of
the cellar when everyone's trying to get
in they're like
railed there you know I thought the band
was annoying it's Rachel
plowing away it's always just like some
sort of heinous yeah I think I think a
lot of this is it like
great shame with sex oh maybe oh yeah
obviously right I mean because it's
weird this is an element to your sexy
dreams is the shame part in the public
there's no sexy part of them it's only
just that I'm in public just you know
really just interesting yeah you're
right it must be like a deep shame and
it's also in public places I mean yes so
you think it's like you're like you're
maybe whatever as you was going to get
out
yes now I'm ignorant but I thought Jews
had less sex shame I know the Christians
were all sex shame really
Christians are more known for the sin
associated with sex but I feel like
everybody has sex chain you guys just
have it like a kind of a a corn a corner
on that yeah well when I was a kid the
Jewish girls were the ones putting out
oh thanks
shout out to Jewish ladies for sucking
us off early on
[Laughter]
[Music]
sixth grade yeah
maybe in high school yeah that's what
like propels oh the Jewish stay away
camp you learn lots of things is really
young and then you kind of just try them
out and everyone knows objectively
everyone's terrible what they're doing
and then you go from there nice because
my best friend and um Jewish Sleepaway
Camp we used to like call each other
lesbian lovers because we didn't
understand that that was like funny we
were just like oh we're lesbian lover
like you know you know so we would just
always do that and sort of like hang on
each other all the time and they had
like a big dance where the boy Camp I
don't know if you're a Jew jewishly boy
campus like this but there was like a
boy camping exact Camp yeah and they had
a dance like on like I think it was like
the night before Shabbat and
um all the counselors gather around this
one boy that I was she just was so
attracted to I'm sure I just humped a
pillow thinking about him for many a
night
bunk and then they they all decided it
was between me and another girl with
straight hair I always wanted just like
straight silky like Hitler Youth kind of
hair oh yeah and they were all we all
want we all want the opposite like all
these all these uh ons with like frizzy
hair I'm like just give me some [__]
straight hair yes yes hate the frizz
yeah you like a nice clean blonde not a
special any evidence
[Laughter]
he's like clean her off
haha
and I like Jewish women so there you go
you like what you didn't have yeah
exactly they all they all went in a
huddle around this guy and and he was
trying to decide whether he should dance
with me or this other girl Sarah and the
Huddle was so quick they were like and I
heard one of the guys permanently
traumatized me one of the camp
counselors like her no she's gross
that doesn't even option those are the
two we're arguing about adult yeah
he's like she doesn't register as a
woman come on have you heard the voice
if I was gonna [__] a kid it'd be a much
hotter kid all right
what's with you guys in the camps I
thought you were done with the Cavs we
don't do the same things okay okay they
feed us oh got it got it what do you do
canoe and stuff yeah okay you did that I
did wow yeah we do like archery archery
and Jewish Camp yeah whoa we do a lot of
fun loving Sports and then every Shabbat
we have to wear like white and there's
some sort of dancer performance yeah
really did you do a performance I did
yeah I got on stage how did you fare at
Jewish camp like they did pretty well
yeah no I got big laughs yeah whoa
oh funny as camper yeah we gotta get
that on the wall
I don't know if I would have done as
well in a Nazi death camp I'm like hey
guys let me do five minutes here get his
camera kill him nothing to sneeze that
yeah that was I was proud yeah I I got
in trouble because I made some dumb I
didn't understand the Holocaust at that
age and I made some dumb song I have to
try to make my friends laugh about the
biggest [__] in a concentration camp
called the biggest [__] in the camp and
it was like I could see your ribs
through that shirt every time the girls
walk by you flirt because she's a big
ass champ and my parents both picked me
up with like a serious about the
Holocaust they're like we've heard about
biggest [__] in the camp and we need to
tell you this is not fun like I got a
theory Howie was that is so funny you
know what's hilarious I got in so much
trouble with this Camp because I
remember I was must be like 11 and I and
I would do like a Michael Jackson
impression where I would like grab my
dick and I'd be like oh you know be
doing them yeah we'll be doing that yeah
and it would kill when a child even the
counselors would be laughing it's a kid
doing this [__] and I would I would be
doing whatever I could vulgar jokes I
remember uh the head counselor pulled me
into his office and he he was a very
serious man and his name was Paul
Schwartz he was a great guy he passed
away recently he brought me into his
Camp his uh the little like little cabin
to like scold me and I was a child I
didn't know and he was uh and he sat me
down and goes it's come to my attention
that you think it's funny to grab your
genitals and squeak like a girl and I
was like I'm doing Michael Jackson I
don't understand this guy doesn't get
here get mad at Michael and he was like
he's like this is disgusting this is
you're you're a disgusting child really
scolded me wow the best part is years
later he's like I was on Facebook he
would comment on my every post like
phenomenal amazing he became a fan huh I
won him over it took me near 20 years
but I God damn it I did it yeah uh well
don't tell them not to watch BT Comic
View because it's all Michael Jackson
Impressions look I was doing hack
material when I was 11. yeah it was the
90s do you remember at the time feeling
like a shame when he told you so ashamed
terrible take a kid aside I felt
horrible I kept doing it but I felt like
[__] I couldn't stop I had like I had
like a nervous director I needed to make
people laugh yeah so I couldn't do that
that's the back of the day when I was
younger
hey I won Class Clown I was proud of it
yeah you got classes oh yeah it was the
biggest thing I've ever done no that's
huge huge got bigger stuff ah maybe
about the time you're not most likely to
eat up Mrs
it was only a dream mark signs his
Netflix special this is the second
biggest thing I've ever done well I was
such a nobody in high school and I even
brought a date to we did the
announcement at prom like best dressed
whatever biggest flirt and I was like oh
and my date it wasn't nothing to do with
me and I think she was off with some
other guy and I won that and I remember
she kind of moseyed back over whoa yeah
so did you close at the end of the night
no no she went down on the history
teacher but she was an easy girl I'll
tell you in high school she was voted
most likely to conceive all right
still holds up
but yeah also I drove a convertible the
71 Cutlass and it broke down on the
weight of the dance which was also kind
of a bummer I I my father dropped me off
and I never went we didn't have any
dances in my like next school because I
was in like basically juvie after that
but I do we dropped me off from school
freshman year of high school I was a big
public high school and our Datsun that
my my family called the Feinstein barf
mobile because my brother puked in it so
many times that it just reeked a barf
none of the doors worked except for the
back door which my Dad held open with a
broomstick
through the back doesn't it say so much
about why I'm a comedian yeah yeah we
all had to climb through the back of the
Datsun and then open the rest of like
the doors to get out like so we all had
to come through the back somebody wants
to get out to get the broomstick out
somehow and then because there was no
hinges in the back door and that's how I
was dropped off at school oh that is a
oh that's tough that's that'll scar you
yeah so I wasn't really cleaning up dick
wise since everyone oh in the house
without a broomstick you know thank you
yikes oh boy those were tough days
regrets and things that I said today
this is the funny point we had the high
drunk now maybe we hit a low and we go
down no this is this is all up on up
with this episode let's go to a caller
I had sex with a teacher in film school
but that's old news that's a legendary
story yeah it was hot she was probably
47 I was 21 22. do you still talk to her
we're still friends not friends how did
you guys hook up it's a long story and
I've told it before but I'll give you
the quickie I had listened to her
I live in Crown Heights I had no hot
water so I was just kept putting off the
showers in the middle of winter it was
too cold So eventually I smelled
horrible and I was at this Film School
like going around going can I shower
your your apartment your dorm whatever
you got and everybody's kind of like I
don't know maybe I'm busy and then she
got wind of it and she was even shower
my house and I was like okay oh my God
but she goes she was quirky too she had
like weird earrings and polka dot dress
and beehive hairdo we attracted to her
at that point a little but I still would
like put her off she's in it for the
shower yeah I just wanted that shower I
was trying to be I was a student you
know this is very pornographic it was so
porny right it's such a corn plot like
who really starts it off like it's an
innocent show or totally sudden I'm
inside of her 100 innocent and here's
the crazy part
I go to her house and she's got a dinner
dinner bubbling on the stove eight
plates eight pots go on the whole dinner
table is like place settings and candles
and glasses and bowls and whatever and I
was like oh my God she goes I'm having a
dinner party they're coming at eight and
it's like six o'clock now so just shower
and get out I said you got it I don't
want to be in your way I shower I get
out I got the towel on my head you know
I got curlers in you know picturing Mark
please somebody draw a picture of Mark I
think that's the artwork we all need so
she goes have a glass of wine I go I
have a glass of wine then I'll get out
of your hair and she goes yeah then I
had another glass and another glass and
I'm like wow it's like 7 45 I should get
out of here you're gonna have a party in
in 15 minutes she'll think I have one
more glass so we get we get hammered how
old were you it's 22 something like that
perfect no one shows up
and we ended up making out and then we
had sex all night and then I went back
to school the next day so there was no
dinner party I guess not party but she
set this whole thing up she had food I
ate her food did you ever ask her or
follow up on no people were the sex was
so hot and fiery and passionate that I
didn't even think about the food have
you ever uh I mean here's the two ways
to look at it either she did that as
like a backup that's what it was like oh
I I is it to get you out or she is that
crazy or no one showed up and I was like
like her consolation prize no way I
don't know but she had a lot of food
cooking what do you think I think
you make all that food yeah what kind of
food did you eat it you're not thinking
properly about the amount of food I mean
like I'm sure it was just some food
which was the actual that was probably
like two pots of food like spaghetti
spaghetti sauce and a side probably
thought that she would feed you after
you [__] her and then and then but she
didn't want to make it seem like she was
like you know trying so hard right so
she's like oh
where is everybody yeah I think I kept
saying like I gotta get out of here I
gotta get out of here I don't want to be
in the way and but how did she first
come on to you she gave me the glass of
wine and I had one before the shower and
I was 22 I wasn't like a wine guy did
you already start to think in the shower
like maybe she's attracted to me I was
so un not uncomfortable I was so like oh
she's an adult I'm a child this is not a
thing she would never be attracted to me
I'm surprised
during the first glass of wine I was
like man I'm getting like a Vibe here
but I kept squashing it my head I was
like that's just crazy and I remember
being in the shower going like man
this is something she took off all our
like polka dot kimonos and all our stuff
like that was she hot hot body she had
red hair she was super sexy dirty talk
oh yeah she was a filthy filthy [__]
remember anything she said I do I
remember what she said well the the
first line out of her mouth was uh we
were standing on her couch she was
showing me paintings around her house
and I was like oh this is pretty and
she's like oh come up here and we're
standing on her couch and we're both
like like you're me I'm her she's like
this one is from 1941 and we catch eyes
and she goes I want you to come on my
face and I was like
wow oh my stars yeah oh my dear so at
that point I was like I think I'm in you
came into face and you came to her class
yes it was a screenwriting teacher and
then afterwards how did you guys close
things out it's always a tough like I
slept over and I went to school whoa you
slept over yeah and she was like cuddle
oh yeah and did you re-fuck in the
morning I didn't because it the bell
rang and I had to get my homework done
and catch the bus you wouldn't say by
the Bell theme you were 22 like like
he's saying this like he had again I
always had to be at school at nine or
whatever but uh yeah it's the college
here stay by the Bell also I don't want
to get too graphic here please I get
more graphic as you dip your nose into
it like it's a taco but
hey folks we might be drunk as brought
to you by sheath this is all I wear now
I bet I'm wearing them right now I'm not
even gonna gonna not but I usually am
yep I am but there's no logo where the
oh there it is sheet baby if sticky
balls is your thing and your dick is
stuck to your leg isn't your thing it's
time to try sheet the underwear features
two pouches one for your dick one for
your crown jewels to keep things
separated cool and Breezy it comes in
tons of awesome patterns to help you
look and feel great it's all I wear I
threw out all my other ones I'm all
sheath they don't roll away which is
good I feel like all my underwear turns
into swiss cheese eventually true it's
good underwear yeah yeah they last and
uh they look good ladies I feel like
like them they love them they're tight
in the right areas yeah not in the wrong
areas whether you get to show them off
to someone or just know in your heart
that you're wearing Raptor red boxer
briefs designed by Donald cowboy Cerrone
wow you're winning either way for the
ladies check out sheets sports bras
bikini briefs and boys shorts everything
is lightweight breathable and ready for
the summer heat go to
sheathunderwear.com and use promo code
drunk to get 20 off your first order
plus sheets underwear 100 money back
guarantee that's sheet underwear.com
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
support the show and support your balls
thank you going cold turkey to quit a
bad habit can send your brain into panic
mode why not just make things easy on
yourself just remove the bad from your
habit with fume it's the Innovative
award-nominated device that can help you
replace your bad habit no electronics
fume is completely natural no vapor and
harmful chemicals fume uses air and all
natural delicious flavors you like this
stuff right Mark oh yeah a few of them
it tastes good it feels good good air
flow I'm a fan get on it nice to hold
feels good good in your hand yeah it's
an adjustable airflow dial and movable
parts and magnets for fidgeting it helps
reduce stress and anxiety while you
break your habit stopping is something
we all put off because it's hard but
switching a fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fumas served over a hundred
thousand customers and has thousands of
success stories and there's no reason
that can't be you join fume and
accelerating Humanities break up from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today at defune.com and use
code drunk to save 10 off when you get
the journey pack today that's
trifum.com fum try fum.com and use code
drunk to save an additional 10 off on
your order today get some few yes but uh
she was uh you know
so it was a crime scene but it didn't
slow me down
you like David Caruso yes yes exactly
that was a blood not a [__] getting more
and more fascinating yeah and so uh it
was a mess so I had to I went back to
school without showering so I was now at
a different kind of filthy but wow
that's fine with it it's a better stink
to walk around with yeah or think of
being a man yeah and my guess is that
you told everyone
oh you I wrote a school uh screenplay
about it if I know Mark it was in like
it was the morning announcement Mark
stands up with like a little speaker
attention everyone she's like
well I did it on Ari's show but this is
not happening of course so it's out
there oh yeah there's not much with you
that isn't it was all gravy all in the
up and up it was a great time
menstruating that is hilarious you know
what I hate when guys will brag about
going down on a woman when she's uh
bleeding
I don't give a [__] I'll [__] do it
when she's bleeding I'm like
other men I would think that'd be the
way they would try to like I didn't
think that was like something that guys
brag about together do you guys brag
about like how well you go down on girls
that's not well just we're up for
anything right right right interesting I
didn't know that was like uh yeah I had
a guy once tell me that he was like a
real oral magician like
he's just a comedian that it was like
talking about how Keith Robinson he's
like oh apparently pulled the card out
of your vagina like huh it's a Spades
he's got the ribbon always brings it up
when we're like hey yeah he's like
apparently I do this thing that women
like who knows I'm like well we were not
in any way talking about this it's like
I guess I know who you're talking about
the dazzles every woman in sight he's an
older man well yeah anyway I know who he
is it is always funny when someone just
volunteers this information like you're
just having dinner talking about talking
about the Knicks game last night he goes
if anyone needs their [__] eating them
kind of a master
very good at eating vagina I know
everyone's talking about you crazy and
he's like I guess I have a special trick
that makes women come three times in a
row I don't know how you call it
yeah he always works it into
conversation I just learned about the
sucking is the move oh yeah at the the
top Nikki Glazer taught me that
um you've talked about sex before that's
crazy Mickey's giving me some very
important tips oh yeah I always feel
like like Sandy from Greece when I'm
talking to any of my other like
I'm like I have what down there well I
never thought I had a thing in there at
all wait there's two parts to it and
other ways you can no I like to tell me
more tell me more like did he have a car
the best line that's on this did he did
she put up a fight
oh my God I forgot about that line that
doesn't age well did she put up a fight
oh yeah what if a fight is rough yeah
how did Slither past us all well the
Grease Lightning song is pretty wild wow
I made a cream oh yeah I mean or
whatever it's the whole thing is
how about that new commercial with
Travolta and they're singing oh that's a
[__] I haven't seen it I haven't seen
it oh my God pull it up it's with the
guys from Scrubs it's a rough commercial
he's a homosexual
um
the way you just said it no I don't
think you did that regret that I said oh
really I figured have you seen this
commercial thing
foreign
this is brutal oh my God
[Music]
oh my God I just fell into it like a low
grade depression this is so irrelevant
how uninspired is this adverb I know
it's like let's butcher a [__]
classic Musical
yeah and then one dumb jump in the
middle yeah it's a sadness of that
little move and these guys aren't even
on TV the scrubs was over 20 years ago
this is crazy well they make stuff I
feel like I guess so
but I mean it's just a weird oh if I was
Travolta this would really bum me out
Olivia Newton-John is she's you know
she's from the grave like I'm [__]
glad I'm dead she got out easy but it
was also very confusing yeah there's a
lot a lot of questions yeah underrated
hotline Olivia Newton John oh yeah who
underwrites her oh my God I feel like
she doesn't get brought up
stunning yeah stunning stunning blind
what was the the music video Let's Get
Physical oh my God yeah
she was beautiful we were little kids
all around her she's kind of got an
Allison Brie thing but yeah there's an
innocence to her that's why it's so
exciting when she puts the cigarette
yes the leather was hot Taps into the
fact that we all want to corrupt a good
girl you got that right we don't want an
already bad girl we want a good girl to
be bad yes you want a nice clean as a
whistle girl that you can turn into a
cup
[Laughter]
the last scene she wears this like black
leather outfit yes she puts out like a
cigarette and she's she just has the
tiniest arm and I want I just used to
look at that arm be like your arms are
Never Gonna Be Like That Just Let It Go
like an arm I remember mentioning that
to my brother once that if I only had
this kind of arms and him saying I don't
know if he was trying to make me feel
better my brother being like arms aren't
a thing like guys don't really talk
about the size of a woman's eyes I love
a small arm we have a small dainty wrist
yeah I love a clavicle too good clavicle
on a lady
[Laughter]
what I would do for a good arm oh yeah
you know like look at how I mean yeah
she was just stunning and then she had
that little she would put the cigarette
out and I always thought that tell me
about it is a way to quit a job put a
cigarette out and like stomp on it like
I'm leaving here
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that was like a a hot scene when
she showed up it never really works like
that though it does it when you show up
at a party where a guy doesn't think
you're gonna be yeah they're right like
oh you and you're hot right it's usually
fly such a badass scene I know I
remember Keith like used to have
um some girls should like come in the
stand Christmas party and you tell her
to go back to the car and I was like you
think that you're that level of man that
you can tell a woman to wait for you in
a car wow go back to the car like how
long is
the power move I don't understand I
don't know if she was his ride or what
this is pre-stroke so don't feel sorry
way before his stroke he still does this
with the story yes you always make
somebody wait in the car
that's like what your dad does it's a
power movie gambling snap your fingers
the car Zips around picks you up
it's not even like a good car it's like
a Subaru
hahaha
a hot car make somebody pull it up like
a Ford Taurus I mean it's all right but
it's not like a snap your fingers and go
get my Subaru [__]
and then get some head in his Subaru
it's not like a story you couldn't be
like I was getting head into Subaru I
sucked off a dude in a Subaru that's not
an empowering story I [__] her in this
grocery getter now it doesn't really I
got road head in a Toyota Camry
cloth seats
have you guys had sex in a lot of
strange locations sure movie theater
Monsters Inc wow yeah Pixar baby like
Monsters stink
[Music]
you [__] in the movie theater yes
she was a kid no
yeah up top watching the movie We're the
only people in the theater back row so
watching Billy Crystal smoking I [__]
in all kinds of weird places Monsters
Inc Toy Story 4.
minions
what a lot of cars I don't know a lot of
roofs
like a controlled environment yeah I'm
gonna [__] outside either I don't want
to go camping when if you found me in
the woods something's got terribly
arrived no desire yeah Outdoors is not
hot yeah especially for New Yorkers
[Music]
mosquitoes is a good point
you wake up and you might back your legs
are just bitten yeah I got into camping
no camping sucks Jews aren't really
known for her yeah
wrestle with no we're not on campus I'm
in a hotel room and like air
conditioning I agreed also I feel like
we have enough like of crazy our lives
are crazy enough that we don't need to
like set up like a possible risk you
know no no you don't need to set up
Stakes like we our lives are kind of
annoying and crazy yeah New York's
intense enough we're good I don't even
like hiking you know everybody goes on
hikes in L.A and I'm like [__] hikes the
coyotes and [__] yeah there's always one
that like never care for a hike no hike
I'll sit by a pool I love a pool and I
love a beach but I've always felt guilty
for not wanting to hike don't care for
hike and don't care for a [__] Museum
no I'm sorry there's some cool museums
I'm aggressively bored in every Museum I
feel sorry for if there's interesting
things why do I have to see them in a
sterile place like they should be in a
more fun loving environment that's a
good point and put them in a party or
something right right I've only put
intended to look at things in a museum
and that's a lot of work to go oh a
naked lady bowl of fruit get out of town
what is that the Renaissance Era or
impressionist yeah it's all fake you two
you're not into museums not really but
I'll go to I went to the Pez Museum and
it was awesome because it's Pez I can
get behind it a little bit the whole
museum for pets oh yeah what what is
what's going on well they got all the
pets through the years it's when they
started in the 30s and there's
collectors and it's fun there's some
cool museums I mean there's like there's
that one in uh Madison's really cool the
uh the military one oh yeah and there's
the uh the war hole one in Pittsburgh's
really cool oh actually that I would
enjoy I went to the Johnny Cash
if it's really interesting subject
matter maybe or if it's like or if you
can go inside of people's houses I like
to go through people's stuff like Mark
Twain's house there's one of those
museums where there's like a room you
can go inside or you could like see the
room the way it was at that time I like
to go through people's drawers so if
there's anywhere that I could like
that's a great idea yes anything I
remember there was an exhibit that my
mom told me about where you could like
go inside of a house and I'm like yeah
can you take stuff like that's all I
wanted we went to my friend Heather's
house and we like went through all her
mom's stuff and um
this is an exhibit you're like this is
this is someone's home I don't know
I actually did do that once I went to my
girlfriend's house when we were little
kids and she lived on the street and I
wanted her white communion dress and I I
wanted that [__] dress I wanted a
communion I wanted to be to be able to
eat that little Jesus snack oh yeah yeah
day and I went there with a [__] plan
I hung out there a few hours we made
some [__] small talk and then she
told me that I could borrow her little
ukulele toy and I stuffed that [__]
dress in there and I ran like hell down
the block and I just when I put it on
and I just kind of looked in the mirror
like I'm Christian now oh my God Christ
loved me very very much
I'm with you my friend used to go to
church when I would sleep over his house
and I wasn't religious so they let me
sleep in and I just go through the whole
house you know jerk it off in here
looking at the mom stuff look at that
stuff drawers open closet run off to a
picture of his mom oh yeah oh yeah dude
really yeah yeah she was a hot Belgian
lady and I had the whole house to myself
I was eating candy I was jumping on the
bed I was keptical I'm still like that
when my husband leaves it's like yeah
it's just like one of those 80s movies
yeah it goes away and I'm like getting
stabbed a body you slide it on your
socks like Tom Cruise yeah like doing
dances whenever I find out he's working
like he's working a a 12-hour shift
instead of a 24 I'm like [__] what's a
Coke in a drawer
sometimes I go home I just start jacking
off I go I live I live alone I can do
this whenever I want oh yeah that's true
yeah I feel like I definitely feel like
um uh I don't know there was something
about Christian girls stuff that
especially and I feel like if I I would
have the same thing as a friend of mine
and my thing would get vowel so quickly
and I used to think like you know I just
want her her things I would hit the same
thing even and it wouldn't work you can
get that bitch's thing and then you're
still gonna want to be that [__] you
don't want it now because it's yours
right right I wanted everything my
friend Kristen pays a cat and she was
like a child model and so a lot of
children modeling pictures up and there
was this one picture with the skateboard
a lot of those kids don't age well
though yeah maybe JonBenet
she looks horrible these days have you
seen her oh she's a little jacked up she
is a little bloated am I right I would
not hit that I would not I will suck it
in
not my type no yeah I mean I just wanted
to be that I wanted that whole kind of
yeah like that whole look and then I
would just she had like these like a
pair of skates and she would put them on
top of her shoulder like this and it was
like this modeling shot that she had and
it was also fake modeling school because
you could send your kids to a school if
you're rich enough and her dad was like
a minor league baseball player or
something or a major league baseball
player I may not minor and I think that
you could send your kids to a school and
and they could pretend to be a model
basically oh and get like modeling style
shots but I didn't know all this I
thought she was a model right and yeah
and I just would try to recreate her
modeling shots and just put on her
clothes and it was really some weird
Silence of the Lambs kind of did she get
creeped out like easy rich or you're
kind of you know suffocating me here
I've talked about this on stage so I
don't want to get into it okay we used
to like like make out with each other
and stuff and play like one was the girl
and one was the boy and it was her idea
I got blamed for it but it was her idea
and um oh you got caught of course the
dirty Jews idea to play the humping game
I think a lot of kids played things like
that I did that too yeah I think it's
pretty common but she would talk to me
first about Christianity before we would
make that was the part that was a little
strange like she had a cross and a few
Catholic like scriptures and we would go
like in our night light and we would
have this sort of serious Christian
conversation oh before we uh that's
heavy she'd tell you you need to find
Jesus and you'd be like shut up and eat
my muff all right
I do think it's pretty common shut up
that's a t-shirt I feel like kids around
that age always do some some weird [__]
like sure yeah you're finding yourself
yeah I know I used to jerk off in the
same room all the guys yeah just kind of
far away from each other
an inch no but we would do a thing where
one time we all finished and I go I dare
you to taste it and my friend tasted it
and we made fun of him for about an hour
that's it
yeah you know it wasn't bad but we
watched the Pam and Tommy video and
really went to town really oh yeah it's
so funny you would jerk off to anything
when we were young I mean it didn't it
didn't take much no you're so innocent I
know in cleavage you'd come to cleavage
sure simpler time yeah Victoria's Secret
catalog huh oh yeah baby oil whew that
was a party Lubriderm yeah
those poor socks yeah they were crunchy
I feel like guys need like a time limit
on their beating off too like you need
like a hard out because otherwise you'll
just do it all day like that's just my
guess but I feel like it's kind of like
a play date like it's beginning in an
end time yeah it's like screen time if
you let it go
go hand in hand you're talking to your
penis you're like you better hurry up I
have a heart out in 20. right yeah
because the road is not good for like
nothing with Comics I feel like you just
lay straight and just and now you had a
phone with porn on it it's it's a good
thing about the tour bus is I jack off
so much less oh yeah and you gotta be
quick can we play some soft piano music
I'm like Gary turn around I'm rubbing
one out oh you got the you're the cot
there what do you call the bunk you
could but I haven't
[Laughter]
you know how about when you're home
visit your family
depends on how many days yeah can only
make it so long yeah damn you go home a
lot I would do anything to just watch
Mark at home just one day to try to get
to the bottom of Mark and just to read
it it's not pretty it's very quiet my
house is my appearance like a dark house
they read a lot yes they ask horrible
questions they don't care about the
answer it's like a museum there's a lot
of weird art Pleasant kind of no
pleasantries I wouldn't say pleasant but
pleasantries yeah but it's very serious
in my home yeah and very quiet
yes I've had dinners with people like
that where I'm like see at our dinners
we you know we have like these very
there's no lulls at our dinners oh I'm
all low I would kill for Nolo I'm
sitting there I got my lady and it's fun
to expose her to it because she's like
this is [__] weird I'm like yes yes
thank you so they don't like start a new
topic no no it's just a lot of
yeah because I was dating a guy once and
I felt like whenever we went to his
family's house it was like it was like
nobody really wanted to talk at dinner
like there was just these long silences
in between things and then I would try
to say interesting [__] to like shake it
up yeah I'd be like oh yeah like I just
played Anne Frank in a row like yeah
detention and they were like no
follow-up questions about that like
never this is the table like I think
Epstein's innocent yeah you'd throw
anything out there just to get a bite
yes in my mind when you get together
over dinner or something like my
instinct is to want to connect so I
whenever I go out with people like that
I always have to like make a pack with
myself like don't over share you don't
need to tell them everything that's ever
happening to you happen to you true in
order to try to connect to them and it
also doesn't work because not only do
you say that crazy ass [__] that you did
not need to tell this person who's not
particularly intrigued by you in the
first place you want me to be like I
guess I finally forgave my father you
know you know they don't want to know
yeah right then it's just another lull
after that yes and it's a weirder low
yeah it's an awkward
when you're sitting down with someone
who gives nothing in conversation when
they just give you like two Word answers
that's my mom how's work it's going well
that's it I know elaborate William dying
here share something tell me something
no well what my mom will do is throw out
the saddest thing on the planet like
she'll be like it'll be quiet for eight
minutes and she's like you know uh
Reginald died
is that right Reginald done how do you
die um cancer he was battling it for a
while that's all my mom now we're back
yeah I have a joke about we call it pain
chambering because we always we always
get caught in this pain chamber because
she wants to tell us dark stories about
people we don't know yes and the weird
thing is Pete she can't pain chamber my
husband because he's like a repressed
Catholic fireman I'm like he's you're
not gonna paint chamber him it's
impossible like his whole life is about
not anything emotional and she tries has
like one leg up and just really sasses
out and tries to tell him dark
information and she'll be like guess who
has covid-19
no one says the 19. and she doesn't want
you to say that something could be okay
she doesn't care oh yeah I'm like I'm
sure he'll be I don't think so exactly
he's immunocompromised she's like yeah
she loves the term immunocompromise
my mom's the same way they love immunity
to compromise what is that like he can't
get well she's like saying that he's got
some problem with his immune I see yeah
oh that's hilarious it's just suggesting
that things won't be okay there's a
gloominess that appeals to them I think
ah yeah the guy was fast asleep once in
high school completely fast asleep I
just heard the door Creak and my mom was
like sweetheart
that love and I'm like yeah what and she
goes that lovely lady the one you watch
in the show in the in the soap opera
she's died and her husband killed her
she couldn't wait till I woke up to tell
me that like she was so excited that at
five in the morning she's like
put one yeah
have you ever heard Damian lemon's joke
about this it's such a great joke about
uh how people who love telling you
people died no they took it off on it he
just got the friend it was when Michael
Jackson died he goes yo yo Michael
Jackson's dead and they're like what he
goes you heard it here first Ah that's
funny
they want to give you the scoop yeah
they're people that have like a whole
album on their phone of just them and
every person that might die soon right
or then you get the people that are even
better the other people you look at the
friend who tells you like a week later
the week after James Gandolfini died
he's like two Tony Soprano's dead I'm
like we heard yeah are you kidding me
where are you getting your news the
[__] weak Lake Gazette
he'll send me like a sports highlight
from like five days ago I'm like yeah
that one made the rounds dude yeah
that's not everyone's seen that one yeah
yeah my mom came to uh to stay with me
once I was doing this college and we
were gonna like have like a girl's mom
and daughter night we're about to go to
sleep and I could tell she wants to tell
me something dark she wants something
something [__] dark and upsetting but
we got through the night like we did
pretty well I'm like we're laying there
in darkness my mom goes sweetheart
remember my friend Daphne
it's not even a name
is Daphne she's like oh honey she's
bipolar like she couldn't wait she
couldn't [__] wait like she just had
to tell me like some personal and they
just no need and I'm like I'm sorry to
hear that Mom she's like well she's
acting out sexually I'm like
why are we they're like TMZ for bad [__]
you know they love it boom boom she's
got herpes and I just started laughing
and I'm like no way she drove our like
Hebrew school carp like carpool I had no
idea she was like a Godless sword and my
mom's like honey it's not funny
sweetheart it's part of the disorder and
she acts out and we're afraid she's
gonna get an STG and I'm like so you're
telling me the Daphne is like just never
met a dick she doesn't like right you
want me not to crack one joke and then
she gets mad and then she goes into the
wounded yeah like we can't talk about
this and I'm like well I've got press at
seven
you heard it here first guys the name's
Daphne it's a very uh particular name
there's probably only a couple look up
Instagram Graham she's never met a dick
she doesn't like give it a search there
you go
and it was like very much my mom also
bring up old stuff that already happened
so I think
you know like one of my family one of my
friend's dad killed himself we were in
high school and then so somebody will
die and she'll be like and then you
remember Scott's dad killed himself
we know that what do we say yeah you're
right way to bring it back yeah you're
only supposed to do that with funny [__]
yeah you watch reruns of [__]
tragedies I know well where do you go
from here what do we say one of my mom's
favorite stories is about somebody who
went on air balloon and it didn't like
that balloon popped or something oh boy
it fell back down and I'm like that's
not even a good story forget the
fatality part is a good tale not much
happens in it yeah yeah she loves to
round back to that hot air balloon
whenever she can't she gets very jazzed
up about that and then you start
wondering when bad [__] happened so they
like yes I have some material I got some
new [__] now they don't celebrate but a
part of them inside gets excited I think
so it's it's like a little dopamine yeah
not to say that we're not like that a
little bit
yeah
and our gossip's a little lighter you
know it's like uh Ari shaffir got
punched in the face we're like
and it's a fun little knives down
mystery it could be anyone yeah probably
it could be anybody
got that
oh oh there you go take a swing so when
are you filming your next special Rachel
do you know yet or not yet no I'm
waiting for your new hour is [__]
great oh boy I heard Webb might be doing
it it's really really great thank you I
can't wait for people oh thanks you guys
I probably I think it's your best I
think it's your best uh stuff oh boy
yeah thank you you just told me that
women shouldn't do comedy I know and
that's how funny I think it is I think
you should be allowed to do this special
others shouldn't be allowed to but I
think uh what you're doing is really
good so you didn't mean it when you said
that I should stay in bed with the
covers over my face I think after this
special you should but for this one you
should release it because it's really
good there you go no thank you Sammy
Sammy Morrell hey hey to A New Beginning
comedy hey they're new beginning
I'm actually when I
look at my phone it's because I'm trying
to remember that the things that um my
pet peeves oh okay
um I'll give you some do you have one
I texted myself a few no no no no do it
you can do Sam's first because I texted
myself a few and that's what I was
looking at just so you know oh I got one
I don't know if we've done this one in
this on this before but uh
annoying Wi-Fi passwords uh like like
good one here's like I'll be in a green
room and I'll be like what's the
password though like it's Olive but
instead of uh oh it's a zero and instead
of I it's an exclamation point I'm like
Jesus
capital and there's a number at the end
and then it's it's Olive uh at but it's
a at as in you know with the circle but
then the letter T and I'm like none of
this makes [__] sense but it better
not come with a story either but I'm
like my dog did this one thing when we
were on vacation [__] off yeah check my
email [__] yeah
thanks yeah so that's that's a peeve I
had oh another one I had someone say
something shitty to me and I and I was
like I kind of said oh that wasn't uh
cool and he goes well I didn't mean to
bum you out and I was like no you say I
said a shitty thing don't put it on me
that's a good one yeah when when they
say something shitty you say I didn't
care for that and then they go didn't
mean to bum yet no you said something
shitty is what you did right you
probably did in fact mean to bomb it
just didn't mean for me to call you on
it yes yes good point yeah damn well
years of therapy right here
cheers
he
started singing that right after like
all there was like a like a bunch of
anti-Semitic things that happened in a
row like Kanye and then up every time
Keith would see me he would just be like
the Jews will not replace
[Laughter]
that's what goes to show you that it's
just it's like
you need your [__] friends to say the
dumb [__] yeah you need Keith is so good
at Ball but we we're just talking about
it with Jim Norton how Keith is so
[__] good at making fun of people yes
yeah and I feel like Keith is like he'll
say something that would never even have
occurred
to you like he is that he is the he
infuriates me and I don't like to
promote him in any way but he is nobody
is one of the funniest people I've ever
met and he told me that whenever his
mother that his mom would always get
annoyed with him with his dumb questions
that he'd have dumb questions as a kid
and he said whenever he would come up to
his mom and someone stuck in my head
then whenever he would come up to his
mom with a question she didn't care for
her she'd be like boy you make my butt
itch
wow you'd be like with your questions
you make of my buddy dumb questions
there was like a time where it's like
now we're so hyper focused on kids like
anything my daughter like says I'm like
let me stop and like honor this and hold
it up in the light and make sure she
feels heard and seen and it used to be
like like my friend Dave Jessica like he
said his he was watching he would watch
a whole movie with his dad and before he
watched the movie The dad would say to
him don't you dare ask me one [__]
question in this movie like now I wait
for my daughter's questions like oh
what's she gonna be doing right and he
said apparently he was watching some
Mash movie it's just so evil that it's
hilarious he was watching some movie
about Mash or some I don't know I guess
there was a film a mashed film there was
a film yeah yeah so he was watching what
is it called by the way smash smash okay
the TV show is based on the movie yeah
so he was oh I didn't know that yeah
yeah Ellie cool badass Jew yeah you're
teaching us a lot of things today
I like movies is Ellie Gould have social
media get Elliott cooled on we might be
drunk
oh
damn who's that it's a singer oh Elliott
she thought I was saying Ellie Goulding
it is a similar name that was a fair
guest that was that was true Elliott
Gould yes he was in Mash yeah he's the
sexy guy he's a cool yes yes he's
appealing yeah so apparently he was
watching the mash movie and he was told
just one thing I just think it's so
funny what like [__] men were
allowed to be in it oh yeah he might
just not want to hear one innocent
question from your what kind of an
absurd [__] do you have to be and
then he just said apparently there was
some part of the movie where they were
using Nets in some way and he goes dad
like he just wanted to know what they
use the nuts for and he's like Dad what
do they use those Nets he's like God the
[__]
hahaha
[Music]
threw him across the room but the Nets
what are those
things I told you that my dad would do a
thing where if I was bothering him
during TV I'd be like Dad at school
today and he would go
and point to the TV like focus on that
and leave me alone and I was like okay
point taken my dad would never whenever
we'd watch a movie as a family he would
never be awake oh this isn't every movie
you'd watch two minutes and he'd be like
oh cool and then he used to be like we
just look over be like this
I'm just sorry that was like that was
like a that's like a guy of a different
era type thing oh yeah dads now have
more energy but my dad just worked with
a workaholic my grandpa was that way too
he'd be like let's watch the Yankees
game I'd be sitting on his lap two
innings in I'd look up he'd just be like
this
my dad also aggressively naps everywhere
but I don't remember I never know I feel
like he's always just like yeah
refreshing himself from nothing at all I
couldn't sleep he was always like I
can't get comfortable and he was like
Jitter and move around all day and like
move pillows he's like God I can't relax
I just can't relax would he talk about
it like he would never would you talk
about his anxiety that's interesting not
really but he would just always be
fidgeting and like laying on the floor
he's like give me another pillow I just
can't relax
it wasn't sleepy like he would just try
to like get a pillow on the floor and
watch this watch the movie with us my
dad is the most particular sleeper on
the planet but then you uh you know but
he would fall asleep anywhere but then
you see his bed he's got like a reflux
pillow I'm the same way I have like I
have like I had a woman sleep over she's
like you have like 12 pillows and I'm
like and she's like none of them are
like decorative they're all like actual
pillows oh really yeah I have a lot of
like uh you know like different medical
things
K-pop latex that type of thing oh yeah I
love him I love those good a lot of
respiratory pillows that's always like I
got that sweet hospital bed
oh yeah that's true you got the nice uh
turn myself into a little taco
oh it's great my dad slept bottomless
that was a treat to walk in on yeah my
dad also um was often without pants one
time you told me my friends to be quiet
at a sleepover [__] ass naked no Howie
Feinstein just imagine that's not good
they said oh you girls suck this dick
that's uh that's a crime be quiet ah
he's just like dumb and [__] and
wasn't aware like went down the hallway
but it was just like horrify Sarah Stern
never came over again that was that
Sarah Stern's last sleepover which is
what my Memoir is gonna be called
sleepover no but that was a rough night
such a Jewish name I know so Howie
Feinstein I mean that's oh Sarah Stern I
was gonna say Sarah Stern too yeah it's
not how was the dead sneezing my dad
would be using was archaic it was insane
why is this noise necessary it's
Ludacris
or when like the San Francisco Giants
lost my dad like this why could it mean
any less to you like it's a [__] San
Francisco
I know even if you're a sports fan get
upset but this this like a sound that
you could never have even invented if
you'd been mixing sounds like a perfume
in a laboratory yeah that's like an
elephant and a T-Rex combined yeah yeah
I agree I think I think putting it all
on the same with Cisco Giants is stupid
the Knicks on the other hand we're doing
pretty [__] well the Knicks are
[__] rolling who knows when this
comes out so we don't know if they'll
still be doing well but right now
they're [__] killing it there you go
but my brothers are we met Jalen Brunson
in that game Jalen Brunson and my
brothers are freaking the [__] out so we
we see Jalen Brunson at the game is it a
room with the Rangers game and he was
like wearing wasn't he wearing a Rangers
jersey it was me Liz the manager of the
seller Gary veter and I see Jalen
Brunson a ranger Jersey and the Knicks
PR guy is there and he's like I think
brunson's coming and he's like just you
want to keep your eyes open I'm like yes
I'll keep my [__] eyes open for a
point God Jalen Brunson yeah so I'm
obsessed with Brunson so we see him
we're in this little room with him and
I'm like I'm gonna go up to him yeah and
Liz is giving me [__] she's like I've
never seen you look less cool
I'm like blowing it I'm like thank you
so much for coming to the Knicks like
you're making such a difference at point
guard and Liz runs over and sees me
fumbling it and she goes he's a comedian
with a Netflix special and he's like oh
cool he's like I need something new to
watch oh that's cool
I was like is Sam was so cute he walked
up like shake it was like a kid saying
thank you for coming at his
so anyway thank you for having me I'm
like wait a minute this is Jaylen Brett
said like he was just like I love him it
was so cute like he looked like he was
falling in slow life he's just turned
the Knicks around he was [__] lovely
at the game was he nice wearing his
jersey one of the nicest guys big fan he
just sat there and softly tolerated
Sam's like you know anxiety whatever
convulsing it was just I was I was
grateful I'm like dude you turned the
team around I love you it was it yeah
yeah and then he kind of softly face
rank him and then I kissed him on the
cheek and I was like I love you I want
you inside me and he was like security
uh the hard part is how do you get out
of those you go like okay no yeah I took
a picture with him and then oh you got a
photo yeah all right I did too for no
reason but because I learned that he was
the person I should take a photo with
yeah it was just like some dumb [__] you
know right and then and her brothers
were bugging out because they're Jews
who love basketball like me yeah like
Jews love we love basketball or not so
my Jewish Brothers and I send them but
also a lot of Jews grow up in urban
environments so I think like if you grow
up in a city environment right but
baseball too Jews love baseball it seems
well I think basketball even more yeah I
think Jewish dads and dads of Our
Generation like our our dads love
baseball and get weirdly emotional over
baseball so yes they love baseball too
and sports but there's a thing with Jews
and the NBA like my brothers it's like
everything they're not like you know
these like nebishy Jewish social worker
and it's like it's like everything is
never there was never a thing that he
could have crunched the numbers in his
own head and I could have ever been a
part of this yes so it's so far away
from us that they're completely obsessed
and they get so jealous of me because
Sam takes me these games they all love
Sam too but I just text them a picture
of me and Jalen Brunson my brother was
like [__] you there's no way you
appreciate this moment like they were so
angry like you don't even understand
what just happened to you yeah like they
were like mad fun my brother was like
that was devastating for me because that
was the last straw of your life and I'm
like Jalen Brunson
if I saw you post that and I wasn't
there I'd be like are you [__]
kidding me yeah no it was we saw the
Rangers beat the Penguins the Rangers
have been [__] hot too the New York
right New York Sports is it's back baby
there you go
slow start but don't get it they lost
their closure for the year you know uh
now there's something about uh New York
Sportsman I put on my story with Jalen
Prince that I just put like Jaylen
Bronson on my deck and I think somebody
was like yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
leave that up and I was like that's fair
that was me I was like he's married you
should post that
get off my dick I'm such a [__] why
would I need to be told to not post that
that's not bad you don't have a dick
it's jokes yeah that's what I thought no
it's not really bad but he was very yeah
he was very like cool but cool [__] yeah
and it was a fun I will say like no I
don't know which thing about hockey I'm
very you know just generally attracted
to every guy that plays hockey but sure
um couldn't be less intrigued by the
game oh really but even live but no
changed my mind I mean I just didn't
care I like that kind of guy like like
sort of a thick neck sort of guy yeah
but I guess it's a weird combo of like
kind of graceful but also a badass
because you have to be graceful escape
and then you also have to kind of fight
yeah
I went to a game like against the uh
damn who they're playing Tampa Bay there
were like six fights hockey's so funny
because
the Rangers were up they were killing
them it was 6-3 I think and everyone's
like the cheap shots coming the cheap
shot basically means a dude's just gonna
sucker punch your team oh yeah at the
end it's insane that's just a sport with
like oh we're winning but there's gonna
be another fight because this team loses
like everything you teach kids not right
right there's literally a box where you
put guys in for fighting yeah that's
part of the game to me so hockey I'm
just learning about this so hockey they
fight every game there's like a fighting
pretty much yeah it depends I mean it's
fascinating it depends but yeah there's
there's still fights but there's usually
just like an arranged fight like let him
fight like animals like true I think
some guys in the team are goons and
they're kind of like I'm probably gonna
have to fight this dude tonight but
sometimes I think it happens organically
like a dude hits you hard and you have
to defend yourself yeah but don't they
have like a fighting section of a hockey
game am I getting this wrong
The Penalty Box if you're punished for
fighting you get to go I sound like
something right now isn't there a place
that they put and there's a party inside
of it [__] fun but I will say this
[__] didn't know [__] about [__]
hockey but I was like that was so much
fun that Rangers game yeah
yeah it helps when you get loaded at
these things you gotta have a couple
beers yeah and you get into it you start
cheering on yeah
punch the glass
I better not but thank you and the
Rangers won right I'm good thank you and
they won by a couple points yeah they
won they played like a really good game
it's a fun hang I had a lot of fun like
that was a fun time hockey again you're
not a big Sports guy right I like live
you like I love live is fun live is the
best dude baseball basketball hockey you
name it the game I was at last week uh F
Marie Abraham was there
and you know every movie Amadeus yeah
every White Lotus what yeah he's in a is
he and his whole family are in Rangers
jerseys which I was like this adorable
they put the camera on him I'm like I
wouldn't do a kind of Ovation F Murray
gets at a hockey game yeah I know he's a
big actor but I wanted to do the place
explodes and not only they put the
camera on him he's ready for it he's
standing in his seat doing this to his
jersey
[Music]
sexual it doesn't like to be a hockey
guy well it's a great sport no I'm just
saying it doesn't seem like he'd be like
a jersey hey look at this thing I know
the other team I love their dicks it is
fascinating that also that level of like
die hard thing oh yeah like Sam like we
went to we went to the writer's Guild
Award with Schumer show and um Spike Lee
was getting a Lifetime Achievement Award
and he stops in the middle of his
acceptance speech to ask for the score
of the Knicks oh that's pretty cool
that's [__] Boston hey that's pretty
great he's like and you know what [__]
boss he's like my wife who's been there
all up but if I could just pause
and say I was like that's so fascinating
to have that level of like well I went
to a Knicks game once and it's just this
row of killer so it was Andrew Yang
Spike Lee Jon Stewart and then Timothy
chalamet front row I was like this is
amazing Andrew Yang maybe we remove him
and get another I'm like yeah we were
doing like [__] Spike Lee Jon Stewart
we might not have led with you you
haven't lead we shouldn't have led with
you who was there Pete bootage uh
Leonardo DiCaprio Hunter Biden
he had a laptop
that would be a hilarious uh Courtside I
know Hunter Biden's here tonight laptop
anywhere now like no he must be packed
every time he's at Starbucks he's like
no no I need this
100 Mine He's a dude at Starbucks will
you watch my laptop for a second no I
won't no I will not I will not watch
your laps a bit that's a bit hilarious
yeah
um do you have any any peeves you know
one thing that bugs me is
um you know when somebody tells you
something
frames it as if it's kind of like a
neither here nor there thing but it's
like you're taking a dig so like I was
visiting my girlfriend and she was like
and um I asked her for some Advil she's
like that's your thing right you're like
a medicine taker no
interesting
yeah it's one of those people they're
like she like will break a pill apart in
like four pieces you know what I mean
like she's so nervous I'm like whatever
it is yeah I'd ask no questions how
about four yeah yeah right I mean it's
Advil you know like whatever she's like
oh
you're like a fat [__]
iron that's your thing you're like you
know you're kind of like a you know a
weird [__] have fun with that and your
friendships are based on that right
right interesting wow it's amazing
people can find any way to insult you
know yeah and I think that she probably
just has anxiety about taking medication
sure or something but I don't yeah I
don't have anxiety about stuff like that
I know yeah I don't care about like yeah
an Advil whatever who gives a [__] yeah
that annoys me also
um
when somebody tries to take back their
apology yeah so my husband is really
pretty he's like well known for that oh
yeah great example
um he'll like lose it like you know I
mean you know he's a
he'll like get mad about some dumb ass
[__] yeah I mean like we were my
daughter had a play date that was like
on our way over my husband was like just
like screaming right before they like
come in yeah can you maybe not like
punch a wall like right before we have a
kid coming yeah right you know and then
later I'll be like can we just loop back
around to that moment where you like
lost your [__] yeah the thing is I'm not
anal you could have like some [__]
[__] wife that wanted everything to be
like this and like this and like this
I'm not particularly hyper organized but
when somebody's coming over I'm like oh
we should probably like clean for a few
minutes so Peter come back from the
firehouse after being gone for like a
24-hour shift so it's like 24 hours have
been on my own with a toddler and I'm
like hey we should organize stuff this
girl's on our way over with her parents
uh-oh and Pete will pick up a there's
like a guitar on the floor he picks it
up and starts playing it like I'm like
don't take this moment to explore guitar
like [__] off yeah we're clearing it
away you know but I didn't even say that
I was just like can we probably yeah
it's like ah
screaming yeah right yes also he is
probably the more organized one out of
the two of us like you yell at me about
cleaning so just clean with me yeah yeah
yeah right explodes just like irrational
yelling he's good at that in a minute
later being like yeah I feel better now
I'm like yeah I bet you do yeah right
you do so then we have like a play date
and then afterwards I kind of loop back
around to it he's like yeah yes I
shouldn't have done that and then he
always goes no need to worry I'm like
that's not an apology no need to worry
is that also nothing it doesn't fall
into the column of worrying I'm saying
that you were a wild on like ridiculous
[__] unnecessary dick I don't think
you need to put that in the column of
like something that I'm concerned about
right right like like covet when nobody
needs to be as worried about it yeah
he's like no need to worry but you won't
catch it I'm sure you got your flu shot
I'm like no you were a dick can you just
say you're sorry right so his sorry is
I'm always he says I'm sorry hey no need
to worry you feel better now right I'm
like yeah I do but can you not do that
yeah yeah and then later but he'll give
me like a exact apology that I want I
have to like write it to him and like
pass it over to him at the bottom
yeah he apologizes like the way like a
kid writes in a yearbook he's like it
all started but things got out of hand
yeah yeah great summer no need to worry
I'll see you next year I'm like no none
of that stay fresh player
hey crash class Cloud yeah so it's kind
of like that and then it'll sort of like
softly take it away again I'm like if
you're gonna apologize apologize yes and
then don't loop back around one time he
was like you know sometimes I feel
pressured into apologizing I'm like you
can't be an inexplicable [__] say
you're sorry and then be like I felt a
little forced to do to have empathy I'm
like no no that's what would be called
upon yes exactly I get you I was a
little too energized about my peep yeah
mine is similar that's a good one mine
is similar it's the guy who says don't
worry about it too much you don't have a
genuine question and he's like don't
worry about it I'm like but I need to
know like I did a club and I brought
merch and I was like where should I set
this up he's like don't worry about it
we'll get it going for you and I'm like
yeah but where do I go when I get off I
need to know where the merch is because
I got to sell it and he's like don't
worry about it relax sit down sit down
and I'm like we'll just answer the
question he's like easy buddy he's like
an Italian guy you know he's like easy
big fella oh my good job some pasta a
glass of wine it'll be fine I'm like I
need to know where to go where do you
actually go yeah so now he's making me
feel like some kind of neurotic weirdo
I'm like I just need to get an answer
and I'll get out of your hair and he's
like yeah have a beer chill out guys
this guy's a doctor like is this tumor
growing he's like yeah
I didn't change it like that so much it
drives me crazy no I just need some
actual answers yes yes do I take a ride
or left to the stop sign don't worry
about it all right I'll just park here
and Google it and that really just
translates to I'm lazy yes and I don't
want to think about this right now
that's it said I will make you I'll I'll
talk to you like you're crazy right
right it's the same with uh like you're
crazy we'll figure it out hey uh what
time what time should Rachel come by
we'll figure it out no you're just lazy
you don't want to think about it for a
second it's so dismissive it's very
expensive yes yes we need to arrange
something and then we're trying to make
an arrangement right so that's
infuriating and that happens to me quite
a lot yeah it's basically like calm down
yeah yeah relax calm down don't get your
panties in a bunch right yes set up
something on a table yeah it's almost
like just being like shut up that's what
it is shut the [__] up shut the [__] up
yeah shut up about this it's not
something my mind wants to think about
right right calm down is so oh my God
calm down it's tough yeah that's a bad
one that is nothing there's nothing that
you want to do less than calm down I
know he says that to you and now you're
worked up ironically yeah yes exactly
how about you Sammy oh no I told you the
the oh sorry the guy in the Wi-Fi I'm
like and now I'll be the host for a
minute I got one more wreck though I
gotta I don't know if I did it because I
wrecked the Palma one recently I was
just I've been watching a lot of movies
just I got cable again so I just was
watching uh The Untouchables on TV Ah
that's a great that opening scene it's
amazing God so many for this [__]
shootout scene yeah it's two depamas by
the way yeah I know I know because I'm
just I don't think I've ever seen that
it's pretty cool yeah it's Kevin Costner
Sean Connery Danny Garcia De Niro's
Capone and it's not one of those movies
where men are looking at Maps a lot I
don't like
no map any movie where there's like four
men who like huddled around a spread out
map I'm like no it's just a bad area
okay it's just like it's like a fun
movie it's about Prohibition oh I would
love this because I love peaky blinders
there you go so this is like my up my
alley I like a fight I like it when they
fight just not when they look at like
directions too much so you don't like a
submarine movie or something no I hate a
submarine movie some of my most
archaically bored moments as a child was
like when I was watching Men watch Maps
sure
the importance
stinks men love Maps they do love Maps
because there's answers on the map
Rachel I got another wreck for you it's
called a u571 it's a submarine film it's
lovely have you seen McHale's Navy
[Laughter]
um oh God in the mood for a comedy Down
Periscope is a great one no I want
things to go down down
wait what is that that's a horrible
submarine movie that no one likes when I
was a kid and we were it was actually a
camp story we were allowed one movie per
summer and I remember everyone wanted to
see u571 and I was like for the love of
God don't make me see this [__] move
we get one movie A Summer I love movies
yeah and I saw Mr Deeds was playing the
same movie okay so I literally went up
to the head the counselor who's in
charge and I was like will you do me a
favor and he goes well he goes just lie
to everyone and tell them that you saw
Mr Deeds and it's the best movie you've
ever seen and he did he said everyone
we're driving back from a thing he goes
guys I just saw the new Sandler movie Mr
Deeds best movie I've ever seen and they
were like really like incredible so
everyone changed their vote to Mr Deeds
and we [__] got to see it you did
those kids a favor yeah young
entrepreneur yeah we saw Mr D and I
[__] and I [__] uh yeah it was and
then you blew him and then he got in his
hands and knees yeah
and he's like you say this I suck you
off
he's like you called it a [__] and he
punched me in the face that's crazy but
my wreck this week is Hunt for Red
October
um but I did watch 12 Angry Men have you
guys movie amazing
Amy
[Music]
and I just go give me an old movie I
need to watch a movie tonight and he
goes 12 anger man I was like and I
looked it up it's black and white it's
1957. I was like I don't know about this
and I just powered through and I was I
was hooked within 10 minutes no it's
incredible and it's like those it's a
play so it's like those old those old
plays with killer dialogue you're just
like oh there's not a wasted word no I
just made a woman watch uh it's a good
point yeah out of the past
which is like
maybe my favorite Noir ever is Robert
Mitchum it's [__] insane Kirk Douglas
is in a Jane Greer is that late 40s oh
dude every [__] line rules in that
movie yeah just a killer script like uh
you know there's a line where he's like
uh she goes I don't want to die and he
goes me neither baby but if I gotta go
I'm going last
just like cool as [__] Mitchell that's
great Bad to the Bone I love these films
also because there's always like a like
a man comes home because he gets to go
out and like do things the woman just
sits there like re-combing her article
and then she's like there's I can't
remember what the film was please help
me if you see this a note because I I
often need people to finish my own
stories because I don't know what I'm
talking about she's dressed to the nines
always she's got like a ball gown on
yeah I said she's always just sitting
there you know and he gets to actually
have a life and she's just yeah chewing
on different medications
and then he slaps the [__] out of her
when he gets home anyway so you're
hysterical
shock of your brain removed please tell
me what happens that's funny you say
that because that's basically what
happens I please tell me the movie I'm
talking about probably many movies like
this but but she he walks in and she's
like you know I've been thinking well
I've been thinking a whole lot he's like
I told you never the guy
you shouldn't be thinking your Dame well
I thought about it couple of things and
I contemplated on him and he's like I
told you not only am I to go out without
you and not involve you in any part of
real life but I'm going to tell you
you're not to contemplate anything while
I'm gone he goes up to he touches their
forehead he's like damn it you're sick
you're cookie brought I'll give you the
taste of the back of my hand we had to
talk about this God damn [__] you're not
to [__] think when I'm away yeah like
well I just said my mother passed and I
got to reflecting on her lot [__]
[__]
uh all right where are you gonna be
Rachel what do you got coming up give us
some dates some plugs oh in terms of a
recommendation too oh yeah please what
was that octopus film called because I
can't remember oh the octopus Master
teacher octopus teacher I think teacher
yeah who's teacher yeah I heard it's
gonna make me not want to eat octopus
yes I do like it I was able to stuff it
right in my mouth oh good it's a beep I
was very touched by their relationship
yeah this guy he goes out swimming this
was out a while ago I'm also watching
everything that's pretty obvious that
everyone's watching like uh succession
oh yeah so but so but the octopus movie
um never been like a I don't know really
into like and she's a person and they're
an animal and then they're friends you
do the math kind of movies but he was
like he went on the ocean every day and
he just followed this octopus and tried
to figure out its life and um it's
completely fascinating very moving it's
a great movie yeah I mean if he was my
husband doing that I'd be [__] Fury
like I'm angry my husband's on the phone
in the bathroom like you know I'm like
imagine if he's just going to spend
seven hours with an octopus [__] off
please that's true yeah yeah I like
getting annoyed when he's playing chess
in the bathroom I can hear the chest
sound and I know okay so I'll be at
emlin theater in Mana Miranda I can't
even say the name New York
um Yonkers comedy club and also wait
this weekend I'm at um I'm in um
Sarasota
New York at Comedy Works as well and I'm
going to be in Dubai
yes I have a show in Dubai as well I'll
be at the Capitol Theater in Olympia
Washington and The Comedy Club of Kansas
oh that's a good one nice in Kansas City
Missouri
um but also yeah Dubai I'm in Dubai I
think in like the third weekend I'm
doing the Dubai Comedy Festival so check
whoa whoa damn not a lot of women on
that lineup I imagine
um actually there's some other women on
that show and um there should be a lot
of good people in Dubai comedy festivals
so that's amazing what a cool Mom that's
so fun thank you I wish my mom you were
my mom
yeah which more normal do you know I'm
hitting pearlies again oh you got to do
it best Jewish deli great deli my fave
Queensboro North Carolina Asheville
Charlotte Knoxville Memphis Birmingham
Alabama Chattanooga Knoxville uh
Nashville weather Denver Santa Fe San
Antonio Houston uh and more samrail.com
shows hell yeah
um also I wanted to I forgot to give you
this book Sammy what is it speaking of
recommendations um it's about oh but
it's an awesome book oh you're the best
it's uh Marlon Brando's autobiography
that he wrote I think with another
author as well but it's called songs my
mother taught me it is a [__]
fascinating I can't wait to know this
about Brando if you're watching at home
loved the Jews had your same fetish Mark
no he's an anti-semite I thought
he told he said Hollywood was run by the
Jews and all that oh maybe that was
later when he went crazy but his life he
was really into juice but he always
blame the Jews in the end when they're
starting to lose their marbles they're
like the goddamn Jews but early on was
um he taught he learned theater from
Stella Adler and he became really
obsessed with me I liked it
um really yes and he just he has a lot
of hilarious stories one of my can I say
one more thing about this book okay
please one of the he was funny I feel
like he could have been a comic Orlando
Brando hilarious goes to his school
everybody everybody called him bud when
he was growing up he went to his school
and thought everybody was obsessed with
this mascot hated school I think he went
out to some like military school or
something anyway thought it was dumb
thought like school spirit was annoying
they had a mascot everybody was obsessed
with this mascot it bugged him he was
like yeah [__] your you and your dumb
mascot so he decides One Night in the
middle of the night to dig up this
mascot like a big statue in the middle
of the campus and bury it like 15
minutes outside of town and then
everybody loses their [__] they're like
where the [__] is the mascot everybody
called him bud in high school they're
like Bud where the [__] yeah everybody's
looking for the mascot he's like I don't
know starts a committee to find out who
took this message like not only do I not
know where this mascot is he [__]
stolen I'm gonna get to the bottom of
this everybody joins the math like this
is almost as good as my Mr Deeds uh move
this is incredible but yeah basically he
basically starts to committee it is is
almost not as good but yeah yeah then he
starts the Committees to try to get to
the bottom of who took this this mascot
and then finally exhaust like the Nerds
the very people that bugged him at a
certain point he was like the most
gung-ho one he's like if you're in or
you're out we're gonna do this five days
of the week we're gonna get to the
bottom of who took this thing like he
was real difficult and exhausting and
then finally basically they came to him
and they were like but we gotta let this
go the mascot's gone yeah but it was him
who took it all along funny [__] guy
songs my mother taught me I always
related to that story about him uh you
know he married that Indian woman uh and
took care of her because she was so ill
and then when she got better he lost all
interests oh really he just took care of
her like day and night and then she like
was fully healed and he was like wait
was that little feather I know
a little Cruise lady was that the woman
on the Oscars no oh that was a protester
he had got it got it which by the way I
just saw in the Bill Maher new rules
thing he brought up how like everyone
loves to say like Hollywood is not is
yeah because he won for Godfather
Godfather
yeah that was like he's that was kind of
ballsy that was his comeback movie and
he was like he's like suck my dick
Oscars yeah that's kind of cool actually
and they didn't make a big but everybody
was booing in the room oh yeah yeah on
camera they were like Boo pull it up
it's on YouTube
it's such a funny thing to boo it's so
reasonable and positive I know like hey
can we support Native Americans they're
like [__] off
I'm in Australia come see me in
Australia I'm all over the road uh
Sydney Melbourne Brisbane New Zealand
Auckland Perth you name it going down
under say hello and uh yeah get some
Bodega cat say hi on the road we got the
shirts on Shameless plug thank you
Danielle
killing it she's a Jew we've learned
that today not Italian we I knew
Danielle was a Jew I didn't know now I
think less of her and uh we'll keep it
moving thanks we'll see you next week
congrats on your special Marco when's
your special coming out uh late June
July Late July sorry where'd you tape it
Chicago
absolutely incredible it was fun
multiple people I heard it was an
incredible I'm the only douche who
thought to film on Saint Patty's Day
which I didn't think about apparently it
worked out because I heard it was an
incredible team it went well thanks to
Webb and the Gang swab James Webb killed
it our boy James Webb we love you James
yes all right we'll see you guys next
week you're the best
ah
[Music]
I've had a little too much person and
Norman's talking [__] about the [__]
post and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
we might
be true
[Music]